hello and welcome to a very special
edition of Backstage the film and TV
podcast from Sky News
[Music]
I am joined today I'm thrilled to say by
our power pundit and general Legend
Stevie Wong and Skye and enter David
corresponder Ghost of Christmas
I'm watching you Katie I'm watching Keen
listeners will know we're not in our
usual uh studio today we're kind of
we're almost all in one place although
Stevie of course being miles across the
ocean is is in a screen but in on in the
same place so uh it's uh it's it's
festive fun uh I like it although Stevie
kind of looks like he's in heaven almost
it's very good
white Place
it'll be very comfy or very festive
um so this episode we're gonna look back
at all the amazing TV and film that
we've had uh offered to us this year um
so that if you want a big old binge over
Christmas or New Year then um you've got
some recommendations some of this stuff
you're bound to have heard of others you
might just have sort of a missed
hopefully we'll offer some bits that
you're not aware of and we're going to
let you know what to look out for next
year as well
um so here's a little taste of things to
come
okay here we go
[Music]
so let's start off with TV then uh and
we did our usual well we've not done our
usual thing where we sort of do some
very complicated maths and later kind of
top ten we just sort of got everyone to
feed into a general list so um which is
why you will then hear loud complaints
I'm not happy every year this happens
and it just yeah this year you're
filming me ranting saying what is this
list come on uh but there are definitely
things that you do like on the list so
um I'm going to start off with my
favorite because I'm the one talking and
I'm gonna go with a house of the Dragon
now it feels like a bit of an obvious
pick and I'm sure loads of people will
have obviously seen this already of
course the big highly hyped Game of
Thrones prequel that arrived on Sky
finally this year it was sort of almost
did battle with the Lord of the Rings
show which was also you know got fantasy
stuff in it and the Sandman as well no
one else thought that the Sandman was
okay
just me
um but I absolutely loved it I thought
they smashed it it was such a good
satisfying series it's obviously been
renewed
oh
why is this your lift Stevie Wong did
you even get into this in the end
I mean I watched it but it was not on my
favorites list
um I think the acting was very well but
um yeah I think it's all right uh there
there are other shows on this list that
that kind of superseded my favorite
shows of the year which we'll of course
talk about but Claire let's hear what
you have to say about House of the
dragon and why number one favorite show
of the year I think you're right the
acting was great the casting was spot on
Matt Smith perfect role absolutely loved
it
um the story was good I mean I know it
was also based on a Georgia R Martin
book so uh people kind of knew where it
was going I hadn't read that book though
so I very much enjoyed being taken along
with it and I'm so glad there's more to
come and I'd miss that sort of
backstabbing world of Game of Thrones
they just do it better than anyone else
but my issue is that it just wasn't as
interesting a world as the Game of
Thrones one was because you had lots of
Worlds going on and this just felt a bit
if you didn't care about the dragons he
stuff I mean but the dragons themselves
are just one part of that small world I
will I will have to agree to disagree on
that because I just I think it was
arguably possibly better than some of
the Game of Thrones
no I'm certainly not like but yeah yeah
I think maybe maybe better than the last
one
um okay well you know but like I say
it's it's sort of an obvious pick
because I feel like most people who are
going to watch House of the Dragon
watched house and the dragon and already
know about it so maybe let's talk about
something that people might have missed
um shall we chat about the bear
oh I absolutely loved the bear I feel
like actually Stevie Wong has to take
credit for this because he was the one
that said have you seen the bear you
guys have to watch the bear it's really
interesting it's on Disney plus watch it
please watch it I've watched them all in
one night Stevie so you take it because
you're the one that turned us all on to
this
the bear was a really fascinating uh
setup because in the US it was on a
network called Hulu and what they ended
up doing was they just like released it
in one go and people discovered it over
time and then what had happened was I
kept on seeing the bear the bear the
bear on my Twitter feed and finally one
evening I was like let's see what this
bear is all about same like you Katie
did the whole binge and then walked out
of the whole thing going like this is
the best thing I've seen this year and
and the only way to describe it if you
don't know what the bear is about is
about this young guy who comes back to
take over his family restaurant and he
comes from one of these like super
um popular and and Michelin star kind of
place and he's now going back to do
these sandwiches in his Chicago uh Cafe
basically and that's the best setup and
uh somehow in this you know couple of
episodes into the most it is so uh
intense it is really really exciting
it's just it's so stressful seeing them
in the kitchen some of it's in real time
and it just it gets your heart racing as
they're trying to put these lunch orders
out so quickly also just seeing that
they that like the food looks gorgeous
I've never wanted a sandwich so much
life as I do watching this
um but also I just think they were just
incredible actors I know like the point
of acting is they're meant to be like
assume other characters and not appear
to be acting but I just with this you
just watch them you just thought they
just seem real in the characters that
they were playing in this and it's so
brilliantly short these episodes
brilliantly poignant at times and you
just watch them all ate them up really
quickly like a sandwich from the shop
that they're selling and you just wanted
more I really hope it wins Awards next
year
we're not I mean they will because
across the board pretty much every kind
of uh Guild that has a television
component to it they've nominated as
like best series best actor best you
know supporting so so everybody that has
seen this really has been uh moved by by
the experience and and you know they're
doing a second series and I'm not even
sure how they're going to be able to top
what they brought to the table this time
around but I don't care because I'm
ready I mean the bear is is a monster
and and I want to be all over him so
that's all good
um next to another slightly
controversial pick on uh on Katie's
thoughts anyway
um uh let's talk about Severance which
was a big hit for Apple TV plus this
came out like right at the beginning of
the year so I kind of feel not that I'd
forgotten about it but I'd sort of
forgotten about it but then it has a lot
of House of dragons that's what I mean
it's been a lot of fantasy in the middle
there
um but then it did turn up again on on
some of the awards uh the early Awards
lists that we've been seeing so it's
obviously also had an impact and it's
this kind of strange concept it's quite
hard to explain but it's sort of set in
a very near future where um some jobs or
some companies you can sever your your
work cell from your um outside of work
self so you have no memories or of what
goes on in the other half of your life
you're either at work or you're out of
work so you can have a brilliant time
out of work and then log in with your
past go in and there's a different you
that has to do all the borings yeah no
one cares about and it's it's I think
it's no spoiler to say that our lead
played by Adam Scott he he's grieving so
that's why he does it so he doesn't have
to remember this grief for kind of half
this time
um but uh it's a weird show and the
aesthetic is really strange and it was
championed by Ben Stiller who also sort
of directed the first episode and it was
picked up off that black list of scripts
that sort of go around and people are
like oh that's good but it took a while
um and now that it finally got done it
seems to have been a big success
critically anyway and I'm making a
second series so that sort of suggests
it probably did some okay numbers but
again Katie you won oh no it just came
out at the beginning of the year when
you don't like anything you haven't seen
recently yes basically I've forgotten
about it which is a very um yeah so you
make a good point there um but there are
just so many shots of them walking down
corridors
it was so strange and I loved it and it
was very clever and they're very clever
but I can't be bothered to watch kind of
thing that's just endless walking down
corridors and making me think too much I
just want short episodes Don't make me
watch these long things that tattoo my
brain is it too challenging on the brain
though Stevie because I I think maybe
that is slightly off-putting to people
it is quite a difficult concept to wrap
your head around I think
it's not it's not like we're not trying
to put physics
onto screen
um I think in this case
everyone's got better as as the mystery
of what was really going on within the
office because one of the members wants
to get her memory back and and it just
keeps on fighting and it just gets
weirder and weirder and so you really
want to see how this plays out
um and I think the second it starts to
go into a bit of an Espionage of sorts
uh corporate Espionage then it gets
really interesting and and uh you kind
of forget about the aesthetic but I
think it gets better as the series
continues kind of is slow but it kind of
oh and there's this really great
storyline and Christopher Walken's so
good in it and
I don't know I don't have to like it
just because Christopher Walken's in it
I know but he is really good in that no
I think you don't have to like it but I
do think it's worth a watch if you want
like a bingy kind of Christmas story If
you're sort of stuck at home with family
and maybe you kind of want something to
kind of get lost in uh in another room
while everyone get lost in like a
corridor where you get endlessly lost
where there's constantly seem to be
being lost in corridors it's outside the
corridors but now you're saying that I
don't I can't recall any but there
definitely is stuff that goes on outside
the corridors all right one for you then
Katie uh possibly uh more for you than
anything else we've talked about thus
far Bluey returned for a third series oh
I'm aware this makes me look really
basic coming off the back of saying that
I don't want to watch anything
intellectual so I basically listen yeah
particularly the most recent series oh
well if you don't have children then
Bluey is this wonderful children's
cartoon but also I think you don't
really need to have children to watch
this it's just genuinely really funny
it's this Australian cartoon dog family
two of them are sort of like toddler age
and then it's the parents as well Bluey
and bingo with the children
um and it's just a wonderfully funny and
I also think as children's programs go
it's just genuinely quite an
inspirational show that it actually
gives you ideas of how you can parent as
well because the imagination that they
have within this family of the games
that they come up with of Faking that
they're going on train Journeys and
they're at the Vets and things it's just
I I feel like I can't quite do it
justice of how genuinely funny it is by
just saying this and making it sound
like some sort of Education it manages
to tread that line where it sort of
inspires you as a parent but doesn't
like Wallop you over the head and make
you feel like a bad parent because
you're not as good as blues parents who
are brilliant bandit in Chile and is it
wrong that I fancy band well that's what
I was about to say and bandits also
become this sort of card Zoom pin up a
bit like the fox from Robin Hood back in
our day he's like the now kind of
desirable cartoon
it's wrong isn't it I mean I
don't you know he's a very uh attractive
dog because he's such a great dad yeah
good dad and um but yeah it is worth a
watch because it also gets quite trippy
and as they've kind of realized it's
such a huge success in a sort of
slightly I think similar vein to The
Simpsons it you know it it becomes they
can sort of experiment more with the
episodes because they know that the fan
base will go with them they know the
audience will go with them and so you
start getting this really kind of
slightly sort of strange surreal
episodes but they actually work really
well and you're right yeah it's not just
for the kids at all although you can
sort of see why people might be put off
thinking it is uh just a kid's show but
if she's got good nieces and nephews
coming over at Christmas get on Disney
Plus or the BBC and stick this on and
actually it's just a lot of fun yeah
definitely
next up not one of my favorites this
year I have to say it's the Crown Series
five right who put this on their list uh
I don't know
let's hear it okay so when it did come
out in the last month
I had such a bad reputation okay
um but genuinely I haven't really been
into the period drama stuff of the other
episodes of the crown but I don't know
whether it's because of custom me age
love
um that when Diana died I guess I wasn't
fully across what was going on with the
Royals and this is just such a Nostalgia
Fest to have that real sort of 90s
period brought to life Elizabeth the
Becky I mean she's fantastic I agree
Elizabeth Debicki is absolutely
fantastic
I don't love the other casting doing it
worse
Dominic West totally distracting because
I think it's a little bit career suicide
for Dominic West because now I don't
find him in any way attractive now he's
done also he don't like when Josh
O'Connor played Prince Charles and I do
think that was incredibly difficult
performance to follow because I thought
he was oh so so good but when he did it
he disappeared into the role but Dominic
West just it's like he's just playing
Dominic West I don't know what the scene
behind the ears yeah it doesn't work for
me I find it too distracting it's like
oh this is a movie you know a Hollywood
version of the Royals and I don't love
Imelda Staunton as the queen either I
love her boy and I liked Olivia Coleman
I don't I don't I don't think it's as
good as the previous one Stevie
I I didn't last past the first episode
only because we had to watch it I think
maybe I don't really care about this
family anymore like I like it for me it
ended with with Diana and and so uh you
know kind of drawing out or bringing
back the storyline of that just kind of
depressing and I for me at least and I
don't really need to know any more
details of how she was uh dealt with and
so so I I don't know it just I I watched
it and I appreciate everybody's acting
but I agree with Claire it's like over
the period of time all these other
actors have like set such a high bar and
so now we're just watching to see who
the next gang is gonna be and are they
you know and and it's it's not as
exciting as maybe the initial couple of
seasons were but um I get it the reason
that I liked it is because it became a
bit more soapy and a bit more kind of
correlation right I think I've I'm
slightly put off by the fact it's now in
sort of my vague memories but I think a
lot of people are really into that
because they're sort of seeing it almost
is like we you know it's been such a big
debate hasn't it you know are people
taking the crown too literally as kind
of a I think historical reference I
think we all know that we they're making
up these conversations and that's why
it's quite funny sometimes because you
watch these scenes and you go
that wouldn't have happened like that
well yeah yeah I think that's true but
then also that maybe kind of uh ruins a
bit of the Mystique as well I don't know
I'm not so I don't I still think it's a
great show in terms of like I think the
production is amazing production design
I think the the costuming the attention
to detail I would always argue the
attention detail in the crown is one of
the best like it's so enjoyable just to
watch in those terms I just I just
didn't love it like I liked the loud I
loved the last two series and this
um and sum up
agreed we must mention it's only just
wrapped up the White Lotus
sharp inhalation of breath the White
Lotus finale oh my God we're climbing
well we're not going to get anything we
can't say anything we're not going to
get into that stuff but we will talk
about just
um the sort of the the the task that the
White Lotus had because the first series
was a mini series it was just a one-off
and it was brilliant and everybody
absolutely loved it so good written a
director by Mike White and it was kind
of very satirical cynical look at this
super Posh hotel and the um the people
that worked in it and the guests that
attended it and it was brilliant and
then of course because it was brilliant
they said oh we'll have another series
and you think oh how is this you're
never gonna ruin it how can you possibly
write another brilliant series set in
another hotel that's gonna you know be
as good and as intriguing and as
entertaining but he did it didn't he
well done Mike yeah absolutely is it
better than the first series oh it's so
hard because now I feel like it is but
maybe yeah because I feel like I spent a
lot of the time whenever I've had
conversation because it did give you
water cooler moments literally with this
because some it was like weekly drops
wasn't it of episodes but I do feel like
when I was talking to people in the
office about what they thought was
happening next I did always have to say
but don't you miss Murray I miss Murray
yeah there was no pooing in a suitcase
[Music]
there was plenty that goes on it's one
of those shows it's quite hard to talk
about without getting into spoilers
which is why we're sort of dancing
around the actual what goes on but this
one was very much more a study of kind
of relationships
between yeah men and women and sex and
things
um but it absolutely nailed it and the
best thing about the White Lotus is
there are sort of no goodies and baddies
everyone is sort of part goodly part
badly morally bankrupt yeah there's lots
of gray areas no one's perfect which is
pretty perfect for a show right what
it's been a good December actually
hasn't it at the end of the year or
again am I just getting ready
and now let's talk about stranger things
which return to Netflix this summer
yes yeah anyway it feels like ages ago
now and the thing about this year's
stranger things is they decided to come
back with episodes that were so too long
too long so they were like oh we'll just
make films instead of TV episodes now
the line is forever blurring between TV
and film
um it was hugely successful for Netflix
um which is good because they spend an
awful lot of money on it but people
really love that um that show did it
live up to the previous series stranger
things fans no yep
in summary I just think it's indulgent
why have those ridiculously long
episodes make it sure it's a TV series
keep it short I mean it's good it was
good to have it back but I just got a
bit weird criticism is too scary it's
too yeah really scary even though it's
not meant to be the younger audiences we
know younger people watch it so it is a
bit they they pushed it I think so
although Stevie you're you're making
faces like you loved this series
I I was I was very happy with it and
also as the characters get older of
course things are going to get scared
the the the uh the people might die and
and you know and what I loved how this
series was it felt like there were so
many water cooler moments basically they
reignited Kate Bush's career uh you know
Eddie Eddie Eddie is a is a rock star I
mean these are all really cool things
that that that became cultural
phenomenons and and it had to do with
how wonderfully uh emotional and people
were invested in in this one more so
than pre the last the last uh stranger
things I think but um I it I agree with
you some of these were really long but I
was obsessed I could not wait for the
season finale I like like I sat in front
of Netflix waiting for three o'clock to
come around to like so I can press play
and I haven't done that in ages so uh in
that sense I really appreciated this the
season a lot more than the previous one
so we talk about films though because it
has been a huge year for films we've had
some blockbusters the movies coming back
we've had the Return of Black Panther
with wakanda forever we've had Tom
Cruise of course coming back with top
gun that was a long wait for that one
um even we've had George Clooney and
Julia Roberts getting back together in a
film that's on top of look we've had a
new Batman and we've had two of the sort
of blockbusting uh Multiverse Adventures
a cannibalistic horror and we've also
had a pretty weird biopic
should we start with Batman yeah yeah so
I put this on my list and I thought
really hard because I wanted my list to
be
um not necessarily my top three films of
the year but kind of reflect different
kind of parts of filming so this was
like my Blockbuster choice so I nearly
went for top gun Maverick but I was like
no I think you should have gone for Top
Gun absolutely loved Batman when I think
about it it really I I should say I'm
sort of pre-displayable because I love
that Noir thing like seven was one of my
favorites yeah and this is like such a
lovely sort of homage to those movies
and I thought Robert Pattinson's who I
actually find quite annoying was so so
so good at Batman
um which took me by surprise and I
thought the villain was great and even
though it was long it didn't feel long
which other films could learn from
um and I I honest Avatar
but even though um it came out pretty
early on in the year it was it still
remained absolutely my favorites
throughout we're going to go through our
list this is the big Blockbuster that
we've got on this this is the only big
Blockbuster really we're putting Batman
Above Top Gun yeah for me I love Top Gun
as well I did I really enjoyed it I gave
it a really glowing review on Sky News
in fact but I that for me I preferred
the Batman and also I kind of think you
know the reason we haven't got loads of
other Blockbusters in there on this list
is because if all of the people with a
seen the Blockbusters the Blockbusters
are attracting people to Cinemas still
there are huge audiences going to see
wakanda forever and
um you know we'll go and see Avatar and
things like that whereas actually a lot
of the other films on this list aren't
attracting those films so that's why I
think we've probably not got loads and
now it's on the list it is quite making
me want to watch it over Christmas
actually yeah yeah you fancy bit of
Darkness yeah yeah
why not immerse yourself
yeah a depressing world of Batman so
yeah
what about weird then I think weird uh
is the Daniel Radcliffe offering isn't
it it was the the uh sort of
mockumentary version of the life of um
Weird Al Weird Al who did the uh just
eat it just eat it all those like um
fake songs
yeah I mean 80s and 90s Weird Al's a
weird character Daniel Radcliffe is
known for kind of picking weird in terms
of sort of career Hollywood roles you
know instead of choosing you know the
batman-esque stuff he's like yeah no I'm
just gonna go and play Weird Al Yankovic
in this uh in this strange biopic but it
it kind of premiered at festivals this
year and it got it gathered a bit of a
cold audience people really seem to kind
of enjoy it and warm to it and but it is
a bit a bit of a silly one I think if
you like Radcliffe then it'll be an
enjoyable watch for you if you put this
one over on over Christmas but I just
didn't really because it was based on
the Funny or Die
um short sketches if you like weren't
they which were about 10 minutes I kind
of could have have just had a 10 minute
sketch and I would have been happy I
didn't really think it merited being
turned into this really long film but I
can kind of see why it's on the list
well it's a bit different isn't it it's
a bit silly it's a bit fun people do
love biopics like they really do and um
but this is sort of one with a
difference because it is isn't it real
yeah it's not real yeah and in Philly
but I think you know we like to see kind
of people disappearing into other famous
people in terms of characters and acting
and things like that so yeah and like
you say if you're a fan of Radcliffe
this is just more of him just having a
good time it really feels like he kind
of got his Harry Potter bank and then
was just like you know what I'm just
gonna do roles I think will be a laugh
yeah and good for him why not
um so yeah perhaps one that you might
not have uh spotted in the year but that
that is uh perhaps worth a little watch
over Christmas big Grand announcement
for the next one from Stevie Wong this
is your top tip of what's going to do
very well at all of the Awards this year
isn't it come on what what are you
talking about you can totally tell that
it's already like won over a lot of the
critics and and slowly but surely if
you're following like all the awards
ceremonies like in this film everything
everywhere all at once is kind of at the
front of the list for so many people it
came out of nowhere it premiered at Sun
South by Southwest and it was a movie
that had been on the shelf for almost
two years because they shot it like two
years ago and um it basically is a
Multiverse story about a mother oh I
didn't even want to spoil it because
it's just so weird uh but it is Michelle
yo playing the mother and uh and and she
kind of uh has to pay her taxes and then
things go crazy from there on and it
sounds it doesn't sound like an action
movie but it is but it's also not at the
same time and uh but how funny we've got
a Multiverse film on the list but it's
not a Marvel fan
yeah yeah yeah it does I think it really
boils down to the creativity of the
directors the Daniels um two guys who
had their or start doing music videos
and and now they are I definitely with
this film they are now at the Forefront
of like what uh kind of movies that I
mean they're huge now and so so for us
to see this movie being the one that has
taken their career to another level is
is just so heartwarming especially when
when you kind of break down this this
movie even more it is about family it's
about mothers and daughters it's about
regret
um which you might not be able to see at
first because it's surrounded by the
most insane images that you'll see this
year and and I it just it's a film that
like Bears watching again again you know
and and which I've done I've done three
times and every time I've I've really
appreciated this movie even more and so
when there's a win it feels like we're
all collectively like winning together
and so it's quite emotional this year
Watching everything do all the uh the
award series The the awards now I think
you know after code does win uh last
year it sort of suggests that the um
Awards bodies are I'm thinking
specifically of the Oscars they're up
for something that might kind of give
them a bit of a feel good you know
perhaps back in the day it was more of a
you know your Oscar winners tended to be
you know the films that maybe left you
feeling a bit but now it's like oh
depressing yeah
really depressing ones yeah but actually
it's not the heavy depressing ones that
kind of uh took it last year and I could
see everything everywhere certainly
picking up plenty of nominations and I
would say Michelle yo is very much a
front runner for best actress will it
get the best picture I don't know I
think so I don't think so maybe at this
stage I'm I'm not sure I'm still
Plumping for uh other things but um yeah
still a really brilliant film and just
like a wild watch like it's so
fast-paced and there's so much in it
that you will not get bored even if you
don't like this movie I promise you
won't get bored in it like it is
absolutely uh intense so um Jamie Lee
Curtis has launched a sort of one woman
war against the the comic book nerds as
well hasn't she by daring to say this
kind of out Marvel's the Marvel yeah
Multiverse films as well oh don't anger
the comic book nerds
[Laughter]
Jamie
should we talk about
um after sun though as well because this
is the next one that we've got on our
list it's more uh I mean you talk about
sort of Oscar films this one is more
sort of traditional uh Oscar bait isn't
it a very small production it's a lot
more kind of serious you you did the
interviews for this one this year didn't
you Claire well it's the first time
um female director doing her first uh uh
feature-length film Charlotte Wells and
um it's I think it's I hate calling this
kind of thing a period piece because
it's like oh I remember that period all
like you know victorians and funny
outfits they sort of said um in the 90s
and it's a really simple story of a
single father who's kind of struggling
with mental health issues and he takes
his daughter on holiday and that's the
setup and that's kind of what it is but
it's just really beautifully told and
actually Paul mascal who was already
sort of so beloved from normal people
and everyone kind of was really wait to
see what he did next and daughter came
out and he had a small role in that but
people kind of really liked it and now
he's this kind of this lead in this film
and it's just people absolutely love it
and I think it's sort of surprised
everyone that he's kind of turning up in
some best activists and things like that
and uh he's one of our kind of biggest
British Stars right now which is pretty
exciting uh and certainly you know it's
nice to see him you know around and
about because he's a very attractive man
basic it went basic it went basically
who voted for fresh on Disney plus then
because I didn't even see fresh wow ah
did I say that out loud Davey I'm sure I
know how dare you I definitely did this
was one of my favorite films of the year
because it sort of took me by surprise
it's again you can't really you don't
want to spoil it um but it is a horror
and
the setup is just uh Daisy Echo Jones's
character called Noah is having a series
of bad dates with guys she meets online
um and then until she meets this
seemingly lovely guy in the local
supermarket
um but perhaps he is not so lovely after
all and
um it's just I really really like this
it's got Sebastian Stan in it who's
excellent and it's one you might have
missed because it just sort of landed on
Disney plus quite early in the year it
didn't get loads of fanfare
um and so you might sort of it might
have passed you by but it's definitely
worth a watch over Christmas new year
but you've got to be sort of ready for
it because it is a bit scary I love how
we paired this film up with after sun
which obviously in uh Daisy Edgar Jones
and Paul Moscow were both the leads in
in normal people and now we see them
going off to do their own thing fresh is
is a lot of fun only because
um Daisy yoga Jones is just she's not a
victim and so this is a woman that's
extreme extremely intelligent she's just
gone on a really bad date and and it the
whole movie is really about watching her
get out of this situation and it is it
is so compelling and I'm just so happy
to see her do something that's out of
the boxes I feel like because normal
people was such a kind of prestige
series she could have easily gone to
star in a period piece or something like
that's Oscar baby but instead she went
and did this horror movie instead and
that gives me an idea of like what kind
of career she wants which is a very
varied smart career and and so that
makes me very excited that these two
leads have have kind of moved into this
world where they are kind of taking
control over what they want to do uh and
and it is all exciting so whatever they
do next is something I'm more than happy
to follow along this is very unlike you
picking a scary film though I know
that's fine I know really good if I
picked it and it's scary because I'm the
biggest worst out there so
um yeah really worth a watch and I
really think a lot of people just even
heard of it and that's the best way to
go into don't Google it don't watch the
trailer just watch it yeah
we're sticking with uh films that offer
just really interesting roles for women
as well we have to talk about um woman
King as well because for Viola Davis
this is the film that everyone is
talking about that is gonna possibly get
her and Oscar nomination next year
Violet Davis and Oscar nominations
no not again but I have to say with this
I think it's uh very much worth it this
is um sort of based on a real uh group
of female warriors who protected a
kingdom in West Africa in the 1800s and
these women I mean badass doesn't begin
to cover it and for to make the film
um they did incredible amounts of
training so Viola Davis Lashana Lynch um
Tucson Baidu they they are all
absolutely out there physically and to
see how they look yeah they look
incredible
um and it's been shot by a black
director who was very clear to the
cinematographer that these women needed
to just look the better than black women
have ever looked on screen before and
the film is so good just to watch again
even if you're not into the story just
the way it looks the visuals the
cinematography is so stunning with this
movie but actually you will like the
story because it's really good it's like
an action film but it's not under fully
action film it's like something else and
we don't see women kind of in these
roles and if we do it tends to be the
kind of Hollywood version whereas these
are just women who are like trained
Warriors it's a different kind of
um setup and yeah loads of actors at the
top of their game it's so so
um it's so good like remarkable that
it's based on true sort of yeah history
as well yeah exactly and you know there
is some sort of controversy around
um that that's perhaps maybe muted this
film a little bit maybe it didn't get
the buzz it did because there was some
uh sort of Rumblings around the fact
that the the kingdom sort of was allowed
the same they've tried to go on even if
it didn't
um sort of you know it sort of profited
from it and and things so people are
saying you know maybe we shouldn't be
making films about that but actually
this film isn't really about that it's
about these women and it is just an
absolutely it's a roller coaster you
have such a fun I cried I laughed that
was that I am going to be quoting um I
did a lot well I'd say that because
normally I'm like Stoney and I don't
usually cry yeah
come on this one happening so um yeah I
think one to keep an eye out for if you
didn't see it
um in the cinema then definitely check
it out but on a nice big screen with a
nice big sound system because I think it
would really benefit don't watch it on
your phone well remarkably as well last
on our list of film picks that's made it
into here as well as another horror then
the menu
well it's not a horror it's got Horror
Story
not scary but yeah okay
um again it's such a good setup the it's
about a group of people who go to a fine
dining experience at a like super
um fine dining-y restaurants that's very
small and you have to get um a boat out
there so once you're on this little
island all there is is the restaurant
and the staff and that's it and you are
um at the best of the head chef there
who um without saying too much has put
more on the menu and food
um our main sort of characters are
played by any Taylor joy and Nicholas
Holt who are just both really really a
list actors and I don't know for me this
this film did fall off a bit in the
third act but they're sort of set up in
the first half is really really
enjoyable
Stevie was this one of you
I don't know all right
um I agree with you Claire I mean for me
I didn't I didn't I didn't mind the
third Arc that to me it was very
interesting to see how uh once uh things
oh see this is a hard one because you
don't want to spoil anything here
um so I don't want to say anything okay
here it is
um it is interesting to see how this
this uh dinner plays out and um
everything is seen Through The Eyes of
Anya Taylor Joy who wasn't initially
invited to this island so she's kind of
like a new guest and so her she has no
idea what the food's about she has no
idea what this person the chef is played
by Ray fines and um so all of the
incredulous and and weirdness kind of is
seen through her eyes and she plays a
beautiful like kind of central character
uh Margot and I I think that's she's the
the reason why this movie plays out so
well because it's somewhere in there she
also understands the tone which is
extremely Wicked it's it's directed by
Mark Milo and did a succession he works
on on that show and there's just a lot
of dark comedy going on and she Anya is
very good at like writing that fine line
of like being a damsel in distress but
also a hero of this of the story so uh I
I loved it and and I think everybody who
was curious about this should really go
in not knowing anything there's dinner
and that's it yeah again I got confused
with the ones that because I remember
this week when Steven was like come on
we're gonna I'm gonna try and get you
all the screeners for the menu you have
to see the menu the menu is really good
and I then got confused between that and
the triangle of sadness and the triangle
of sadness is a very different film yeah
and there's a lot of awful
awful scenes in the Triangle of sadness
and then yeah realized that this wasn't
the one yeah also I think like yeah if
anything this year
some of the things that happened on that
boat
oh yeah a very different kind of
although also worth a watch you know no
oh no oh no with that one makes my
stomach but I think I think 2022 is
really the year that we are more than
happy to make fun of the Rich and I
think that's been a riding theme for for
a lot of these movies and even TV series
White Lotus is kind of a look at at the
ultra wealthy and stuff too and so so we
are more than happy to see them all go
down
because I don't know maybe it's
culturally this is a thing that would
that we want to watch on our screens
well it wouldn't be backstage without
talking to a uh wealth of Hollywood and
television stars and what a year it's
been in terms of talking to the
celebrities we've had everyone on we've
spoken to Sylvester Stallone Jeff
Bridges Kate Winslet Radcliffe Brad Pitt
uh Jessica Justine Dave blooming growl
hard we've been busy haven't we should
we take a listen now to some of the
stars that we've spoken to well if you
join us here on the red carpet for the
premiere of bullet train is classy the
fight scenes are incredible the Cuba is
great and it starts the man who is next
to me right now
it's very loud right now but then you're
like wait hold on that's me
continue
hold on a second so yeah this is life
this is wonderful and everything became
I kind of hyper precious during that
time there is a sweetness and a kindness
and a joy to all of this does the
character secretly want to be a wakandan
that's funny uh no I don't think he does
I have had to push the button if I don't
I will never be the artist that I've
always dreamed I could be you played me
one day as a crazy person I'd be
delighted yeah
exactly so when the operating
opportunity came I thought well we're
probably the only band
um that would do something this
ridiculous so we might as well I don't
think there's 30 seconds to go by that
she doesn't say something humiliating
about me which it cracks me up but in a
in and nice it is very rotten nice way I
love women's stories so much and so I
get really inspired by the strength of
women I found I grew up wearing the
history books never really talked about
how incredibly
um Dynamic and exciting and brave and
heroic women are I'd like to do
something like that not so much for it's
not about the money I just want to do
that for memory and he asked and I said
yes I mean why on Earth did I not also
my children would never have allowed me
to not say yes yeah they were like mums
do it it's so exciting he's sending the
script they're like just just do it just
do it thank you so much for your time uh
it's been a joy to chat to you
congratulations on the Emmy hey thanks
so it's so lovely to see you booked and
busy and I hope the show goes well hey
thank you so much yeah all right so as
we close out 2022 let's look ahead to
next year and the promise of big big
shows and films coming our way so gang
what do you think is going to be the
things that we're going to be talking
about all next year oh I think the power
I mean it's uh a lot a lot of this stuff
is kind of coming up quite soon next
year so I don't know if it's slightly
cheating but I'm gonna kick off with the
last of us
um which is already sort of starting to
get bubbly hype over here because I
think it comes out right at the start of
based on the video game yeah this is
based on a video game
um and it has a massive massive cult
following lots of people say it's kind
of one of the best games of all time
it's about Joel and the teenage girl
Ellie um who they are kind of uh brought
together and and kind of trying to find
their way through life drawing a Brutal
Zombie Apocalypse it doesn't like a
zombie apocalypse and I know that it's
sort of we sort of feel a bit like ah
Zombie's not done as sort of The Walking
Dead sort of limped off this year didn't
it but um but actually the expectations
are very high for this and I think
that's partly because it's got the Stars
art Pedro Pascal who I mean come on like
he is like just riding high at the
moment and then Bella Ramsey who so
great in that film she led a film
Catherine called birdie Catherine called
birdie yeah we talked about that on the
podcast and it was a decent film it's
directed by Lena Dunham it perhaps
didn't have loads of cut through but
this will probably be what then launches
Bella Ramsay into household name kind of
stardom uh it's produced um by HP HBO so
you know when we talk about really great
shows of last year they were behind some
of them the the bar is high so huge
expectations for this but I've got a
feeling they're going to live up to it
ooh the fablemans is the big one that
everyone keeps going on about as well
don't they Stephen Spielberg's
semi-autobiographical yeah um take on
his uh life as well I mean you guys have
seen it I haven't actually seen it yet
because it doesn't come out in this
country yet but yeah we've caught it at
a film festival didn't you it's gonna be
I think
um one of those a much like West Side
Story actually where people that see it
really love it and
um it kind of is critically acclaimed
West Side Story of course won an Oscar
for Ariana Dubose and was was up for and
many more I think this personally is the
biggest threat to everything everywhere
all at once at the Oscars it could be
very much in the running for best
picture I think if the academy are
minded to
um award Steven Spielberg for his
lifetime of brilliant work that it would
be for something like this which is
semi-autobiographical rather than your
West Side Story which is obviously a
remake
um and all that aside it's just a really
really nice film it's a great film
sometimes it's just your time isn't it
something of the Oscars is this
Spielberg's time
um but Stevie thinks no
I don't want to get into trouble because
there's so many brands of Steven
Spielberg but uh I think this film is is
fine
it has some wonderful performances and
uh sure yeah I'm I'm all about
everything so yeah you can say whatever
you want but I will be on that
everything everywhere train uh to the
end okay but what else is on your list
then Stevie
well I mean what what year of 2023 then
without a film called cocaine bear uh
the only the only kind of movie I want
to see I have a weird feeling that that
next year will make me extremely happy
because there's so many weird
um kind of high concept genre movies
that like sound so stupid that you have
to watch it in the cinema and so This
falls into that in in that world it is
exactly what it is a bear take some
cocaine yeah that that is all I wanted
yeah
it's sort of based on a true story I'm
like how I know it's a true story
it didn't end well with the bear yeah so
I think like they changed the whole
thing it's just like the bear finds a
big block of cocaine and and then
everybody in that Forest has to are
there any actors
who has a sort of uh sort of hits and
misses I would say fair to say about her
was sticking with wild fun and silly I
opted for the Barbie film yeah yeah is
that wrong with me I know it's probably
going to be awful but just when you look
at the pictures of how Margo Robbie and
Ryan Gosling look it just looks
tremendous it's directed by Greta
gerwick come on it has to be quite funny
doesn't it oh and Will Ferrell's playing
um the CEO of Mattel yeah so there's
gonna be some some laughs in there all
the quality is there isn't it it's got
all the ingredients to be a really great
movie We're promised constant wardrobes
changes as well like they are Barbies
yeah yeah no I think it's going to be
really good and we don't actually know
that much more about it other than what
you said Katie and yet the buzz around
it has been huge those there was like a
tiny bit of footage uh like pop footage
of when you want to be there like
rollerblading
and it was huge it went everywhere I
think expectations high for this this is
what I mean I think next year of course
there's still things like the fablemans
which but I think people are it's fun
people are want some fun stuff they want
some wacky stuff they want some wild
stuff and now that you know you know
we're so used to kind of our big
Blockbusters coming out all the time
people are looking aside from that like
what's a bit different what what I do
love how we've just raved about 2022 and
now we're like oh no actually that was
rubbish next year though it's gonna be
really funny and we're gonna enjoy that
not like this old rubbish but yeah um
back to TV then one of your favorites uh
a return to uh the world of succession
now can they keep up the quality it's so
hard isn't it I mean they've Managed IT
so far haven't they but you just think
how can it keep being so good on a
cliffhanger from last season where it
was just the ultimate Twist of the dad
turning on the rest of the family as
children and oh it's every single time
they end those Seasons with a
cliffhanger that just has you going
I can't wait I can't wait I can't wait I
literally can't wait and I'm very
excited and and yeah this is going to be
a good year that we get succession back
um and also returning is of course
Doctor Who
um but a new era many think that this is
going to be a new and great area for
Doctor Who Russell T Davis is back in
the writer's room and uh well oh it's a
bit confusing if you're not a Whovian
I'm not
um but David tenants regenerated but we
know that shooty Gatt was actually going
to come so we've got four tenant
episodes yeah I think so
um yeah it's uh what a pick shooting out
it was very exciting to have him as a
doctor very exciting and I think hopes
are really high for this new iteration
people that have sort of stuck with
Doctor Who through
um what's been perhaps not the most
lauded era feel like it's going to come
back to to kind of being very Zeitgeist
again so will you be watching Stevie up
definitely looking forward to this one
uh shitty got was like some actor that
I've been of course loving in sex
education and just to see him take on
this iconic role and see what kind of
energy he brings to the table is going
to be fun um Yasmine Finney who was in
Heart Stopper she's going to be the
companion this year and so to have a
transactor kind of be the the the the
other lead in in this kind of uh system
like you know the doctor who's been
around forever and so for them to really
go out and like kind of change the the
script a little bit is extremely
exciting which also means that they are
in for something new maybe we'll see a
totally different type of doctor who may
be a little bit more sexual I don't know
it'd be kind of interesting so so I
can't wait to see what they do with
Doctor Who this this season so uh yeah
Bring it on Bring it on this question
yeah oh yeah in the mood don't do all
your binging over Christmas and New Year
and prepare for all the new stuff now
yeah yeah
um that is it for this episode and in
fact this year so thank you so much for
uh joining us on Backstage we will be
back in January of course with more news
reviews and Hollywood interviews uh but
for now have a very merry Christmas and
a lovely New Year bye
[Music]
good